your husband just released a new book
featuring immigrant paintings and
stories
um when he started painting he wasn't as
good as he is now i've heard so how did
you as a teacher encourage his work
or was this like the speeches and you
just laid low
i laid low
but actually he he's really gotten good
i'm shocked i mean he was not interested
in
art at all the white house has a major
collection of american art of course he
never really looked at it so i was very
surprised when he took up painting but
he's gotten to be really good that was
one of his first paintings that's
amazing
but now of course these are the
portraits of immigrants that are at the
bush center
in dallas and i want to invite everybody
come to the bush center and
see the paintings there are immigrants
that you know
like henry kissinger or madeleine
albright or than people that you don't
know
that have immigrated to the united
states and it's their paintings their
portraits
and their stories man they're beautiful
i
i have tried so hard to paint i tell you
what i am the worst at it
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe if you don't i'll be
trapped in this box forever